man who gets us started every single day
on pro football talk uh live at pro
football talk on twitter and his book
playmakers is if i'm not mistaken let's
see uh it comes out two weeks
from wednesday i will say i'll say that
it's march 15th i don't know i know it's
the last day of february and it's not a
leap year math is not i was told there
was no math on this but anyway it comes
out on march 15th and it is also a book
where you can pre-order it right now
where all books are sold mike florio
back here on the rich eisen show how you
doing mike doing great rich two weeks
from tomorrow two weeks from tomorrow
monday two weeks down from tomorrow
fantastic
well you're following you're all ready
uh for the second or third edition or
for paperback you've got a whole chapter
on uh on kylie murray's statement that
i'm holding up right here i mentioned
well i think the statement itself would
be a whole chapter
what guess hopefully in larger print
what did you how did this one hit you
mike well it doesn't surprise me because
i think the subtext of what happened
with calamari three weeks ago when he
scrubbed
the cardinals from his social media
pages which has great significance to 24
year olds because that's how they
communicate and that's how they send
messages and then the report from chris
mortensen from super bowl sunday
citing an unnamed source or unnamed
sources that regard murray as
self-centered finger-pointing and
immature i think that this is
pro part of the broader
back and forth
aimed at sending messages about
the amount of money that's ultimately
going to be available to caller murray
and i think that
that murray's agent understands slash
believes that whether it's
chatter about murray maybe not being the
ideal quarterback although plenty of
quarterbacks if they're in a situation
where things aren't going their way will
come off as self-centered
finger-pointing and immature like tom
brady when things aren't going his way
but
eric burkhart represents both murray and
cliff kingsbury
both guys are in line for new contracts
with kingsbury after the season ended
there was some chatter that michael
bidwell the owner of the team was livid
and there was talk that maybe kingsbury
would be out and i think burkhardt
didn't react to that well and when he
controls the relationships with both
guys and they're sort of tied together i
think this all comes down to money and i
think that's why his message was let's
have actions not words
and maybe those reports we saw about
kingsbury about murray trace back to an
effort by the cardinals to position this
in a way that doesn't entail shattering
the piggy bank the way that burkhart may
want them to well i mean but how does it
you know but you know any agent knows
it's about contractual control and
other than making things uncomfortable
for
a little bit more uncomfortable than it
might already have been for cliff
kingsbury and steve kind when they have
their combine
um
appearances on tuesday at 1 45 and 3 p.m
local time respectively what what does
this accomplish what is this
accomplishment it doesn't accomplish
anything it's just part of the posturing
that
sometimes is engaged in to involve the
public and the media
in setting the stage for whatever the
number is going to be i don't know what
eric burkhart wants for kyle murray i
don't know what he wants for cliff
kingsbury but when you look at how the
team went from
ten and two
to one and done in the postseason
halfway through the year we're looking
at murray as the mvp we're looking at
the cardinals as the best team in the
nfl and they fell apart and for nine
straight seasons kingsbury is a head
coach at texas tech for six years and
three seasons with the cardinals he's
had good great starts and he's tailed
off down the stretch now
you can also say well his team's
ultimately gotten better each year in
arizona and that's accurate but it
doesn't change the fact that
he tends to flame out the rest of the
league tends to catch up with him as the
season goes on and the same is true of
kyle murray and that ankle injury
suffered week eight thursday night game
against the packers it came down to that
throw to aj green when aj green didn't
know the throw was coming his way and
they could have won that game if aj
green makes that catch
that's when murray suffered the ankle
injury to play before that and i don't
think he was the same all season long he
definitely wasn't the same guy in the
playoff game he had two carries for six
yards so this is about figuring out what
the right number is hey it's one thing
to say we're going to give you a
contract but how much we're going to pay
you are you going to be getting 40
million a year are you getting 30
million a year that's a big difference
and i think that the cardinals are going
to try to push toward the lower end of
that and burkhardt is going to try to
push his guy toward the higher end of
that and the question is can they find a
middle ground before we get to the start
of season where he's due to make i think
five and a half million in total
compensation well that's a number that's
not even remotely close to his level of
uh play or or his value i mean that's
that's always true for r jackson he
didn't get a contract different
different circumstance though jackson
represents himself and wouldn't engage
the ravens the ravens would have done
something if they could have gotten
lamar jackson's attention so this year
the question is you've got an agent
who's engaged you've got a team that is
interested
can you get the two circles of the venn
diagram to come together that's going to
be the challenge for both sides as we go
forward mike florio here on the rich
eisen show
how is the
so he's not gonna be available right
like this quarterback carousel is not
gonna involve number one despite
you know by the way excellent stationary
um and despite this
this statement right like he he's not on
the this is not gonna happen does any
quarterback have a good personal logo
i don't know so many of them have
personal logos
i don't like any of them really you
don't like the tb12 i don't like the tv
you get used to it because you see it
everywhere yes but like the russell
wilson logo not good just the logos
aren't good whatever they're paying and
they're probably paying a lot to some
graphic designer to come up with these
things they're just not getting the bang
for their buck anyway
so it's due
then let's let's get to the quarterback
carousel here mike florio on the rich
eisen show on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line so
what does the
the quarterback carousel look like does
it involve kylie murray or this just is
not going to deteriorate no unless we're
a couple statements away from that
what do you think anybody that would
want him is going to have to be ready to
give him what he wants financially and
give the cardinals what they would want
so i think that complicates things and i
don't know who out there would be
clamoring to make him one of the highest
paid quarterbacks in football and give
the cardinals whatever it would take to
make it happen you have to be willing to
listen to anyone who calls you and makes
you an offer every player that you have
in a contract that contract is an asset
that you can
flip into
something that may be more and if you
don't view this guy as one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl and someone else
does and they're willing to pay him
accordingly and pay you accordingly you
have to at least listen i'd be surprised
if it happens though and i think there's
a lot of people out there who just would
not want calamari to be the quarterback
at all that's something sims has said on
pft live and i agree with him there's
just
uh you know he's too short for some for
some coaches for others he's not but for
some they're just gonna say no it's a
non-starter and and you know when you
take away the running ability he looks
even shorter than he is because then
he's stuck back there in the pocket and
he's trying to find his way through the
the throwing lanes and and if he's not
going to pull down the ball and take off
with it it's not that same level of
threat that we've seen when he's at his
best so i don't think he's going to be
on the carousel but all it takes is one
team to contact the cardinals and say
hey you know we're willing to give this
guy what you're not and we're willing to
give you a lot to make it happen and
let's do something the cardinals would
have to at least take it seriously but
be stunned if it happens it has to be so
much and you know as a practical matter
if you're going to trade for somebody
you have to give up to get him from
another team and what you have to give
up to get him under contract that's
a sliding scale and the more you pay
the player the less you want to give up
in draft pick compensation the more you
give up in draft pick compensation or
player contracts the less you want to
pay i just think it would be too hard to
pull it off and i just don't think we're
even going to go there i i i'd like to
think this ends with an acceptable
contract for kyla murray but you know
we'll see there's going to be more
huffing and puffing before they sit down
and work this thing out well let's talk
rodgers i had diana rossini on the show
um and she mentioned the the the number
50 million a year um mcafee said he
spoke to rogers and he called that
report false i saw your
post on it i agreed uh with what you
said uh i'd said it earlier in the day
as well i think if he's
50 million's worth it i mean like we're
talking about a lebron extension in the
nba two years 97 million
um why not that for aaron rodgers if
he's playing as well as lebron is at his
age in his sport right after the packers
lost to the 49ers in the playoffs i
wrote at pft that if the packers want to
avoid aaron rodgers off season drama 2.0
there's an easy way to fix it go to him
right now and offer him two years 100
million fully guaranteed that's 50
million a year
if you fully guarantee it it makes
jordan love moot for the remainder of
his rookie contract he's got two years
left under contract
with the
fifth year option available but that's
the easy way to do it that's what i
wrote and in response to that i heard
from somebody
connected to rogers and i know he swears
no one connected to him talks and i'm
i'm shocked he's that naive because
everybody talks especially
when they're trying to help their client
and what i heard was you're barking up
the wrong tree it's not about money at
this point they offered him a huge
contract last year it's not about money
it's about where he's happy it's about
where he's comfortable it doesn't matter
how much he's getting what matters to
him is where he's playing now we're
wired to believe that whenever someone
says it's not about money it's
absolutely about money and if it is yes
50 million per year is fair for the back
to back regular season mvp and when we
see where the salary cap is going
because the first line of defense is oh
the salary cap
you can make it work under the salary
cap that that's just something that the
teams throw out there to justify not
doing what players want them to do you
can make it work and each year the
salary cap is going to go up more and
more and more with the pandemic behind
us with the new tv deals kicking in with
the gambling revenue increasing all the
time and anything you do to kick cap
dollars into future years those cap
dollars are going to mean less in future
years because the total cap keeps going
higher and higher so they can make it
work without him accounting for 25
percent of the salary cap right now they
could pay him 50 million a year and they
could push all that money into future
years and rip the band-aid off when the
cap is a lot more than the 220 million
or whatever it's going to be this year
so yes i think he deserves it
there's nothing unreasonable with
wanting it i'm just not sold on the idea
that it really is an issue for him at
this point it's more about where he's
going to be and what he's going to do
and you know he said 17 days ago
that a decision
will come pretty quickly after he takes
a couple of weeks to think about it we
are in that range now and if we're here
we are 16 days away from the start of
the league year he said multiple times
before free agency begins he's going to
make his desire known and rich i think
the entire quarterback carousel
hinges on him that the teams out there
that are considering which quarterbacks
they're going to go after i think
everyone's going to wait and see what
happens with rogers before some of these
deals get done i think that's one of the
reasons why we haven't seen any of the
unofficial trades like the the stafford
to the rams which was weeks before the
start of the league year the alex smith
to washington from several years ago i
just don't think we're going to see any
of that until rogers makes his
intentions known yeah so he um is a
linchpin of it what about russell wilson
what do you think
i think at the end of the day he's going
to stay in seattle i think he needs to
re-establish himself and i'm not sure
that
you're going to get the same market for
him this year as we saw last year
because there's questions about whether
or not he's in
an early stage of overall physical
decline and it may just be that other
younger quarterbacks are so good that in
comparison to them he doesn't look as
spectacular as he used to but he doesn't
move like he used to he doesn't run like
he used to and then when he suffered
that finger injury on a thursday night
when his hand encountered the helmet of
aaron donald he was never the same the
rest of the year and i know it was
heroic for him to return when he did he
got back on the field but he was just
never
the same guy throwing the ball he's not
the guy he used to be
running the ball
and i don't know that that i i put
together
a gigantic package to try to get him
especially because
he may want a new contract on the way
through the door and he's always put
himself in a position where when it's
time to negotiate his agent who
represents no other nfl players he's the
tom hagan of nfl agents he's got one
client he always drives a hard bargain
because he doesn't have some broader
dance that he has to be sensitive to
where he's going to piss somebody off as
it relates to this client or that client
he always drives a very shrewd hard
bargain for russell wilson and that's
out there he's got two years left on his
contract and he typically does a deal
with one year left and if there's going
to be a trade he's probably going to
want that new deal right now so i think
it's going to be tough to do and the
seahawks
i can see the seahawks convincing him to
give it one more shot in seattle and
then if it doesn't work this year then
next year would be the the time that
russell wilson gets moved mike florio
here on the rich eisen show so give me a
give me a team that would make a big
swing at quarterback that would up that
that would spin that carousel or a
quarterback that
can um
can raise his hand and say i want out or
publicly or not like stafford was that
guy last year and the rams were that
team so what do you think well where's
the team this year that you look at and
say you're definitely going to put
yourself in a situation where the deck
is stacked in your favor if you go there
and i kind of think that's why at the
end of the day
aaron rodgers may stay put i i've gone
from thinking he's definitely going to
ask to leave to maybe he's going to
realize that you know if he goes
somewhere else
and they have a strong regular season
and don't get to the super bowl then and
then maybe all of a sudden the narrative
shifts from the packers can't put a
winner around aaron rodgers too aaron
rodgers can't finish the deal
with uh you know a team that does really
well in the regular season and then
peter's out in the postseason you look
at the afc and and that's where i think
the packers will want to send him
they're not going to want to have to
contend with him even though they may
not have to worry about that post rogers
looking at the quality of their
quarterback option we still don't know
what jordan loves going to be but you
know let's say rogers ends up with with
someone like the steelers or
or the broncos or and the broncos are
the are widely regarded as the front
runner i i i just
i i don't think you can look at
a destination for rogers as some sort of
dramatic upgrade like it was for brady
going from a patriots team that was in
decline to the buccaneers stafford going
from alliance team that's perpetually in
decline to the rams the packers are the
two-time defending number one seed who
have failed to parlay that into a super
bowl win where do you go if you're
rogers where you can feel confident
that
that you're gonna strike gold and make
it three for three quarterbacks with new
teams getting a super bowl win right out
of the gates i think it's tough to find
a spot the colts intrigue me i don't
know that aaron rodgers is interested in
the colts but they're clearly done with
carson wentz you think and right 0-2
lifetime at indy so he knows it's hard
to win in that building i and it's you
know you play all your games in a dome
you don't have to worry about the cold
and the wind and the rain
i if they could pull it off that would
be something
and you think they're done with wince i
think it's done with once there's been
too much noise about them being done
with wence with no pushback whatsoever
from the colts to make me think it has
to be true that they're done with once
the question is what can they do with
them and you know if the steelers are
going to go with mason rudolph then
that's the easiest that's the easiest
answer right i mean come on mason
rudolph's probably a nice guy i don't
know him personally but but give me a
break have we not seen enough from mason
rudolph well i mean no way in hell is
mason rudolph no i know that the
quarterback of the steelers and we had
our friend rick stroud on the show last
week as well from tampa bay um the tampa
eight times and he said you know similar
what ed bouchette said when he came on
is like look this is what they have now
this is what they've got now like if it
started now this is the guy now
um and the question is is like who who
if not him then who
and for the steelers bouchette said
there's no way they're making a big
swing they might draft somebody maybe
maybe you know like instead of a big
swing a check swing at quarterback like
uh winston or
jimmy g maybe you know
or uh and then tampa
i threw out the name of brady maybe
coming back you know once he's done
hanging out with lily tomlin he then
decides
that there's more than
more than just a movie right like that
that's that's where he went with the
gabbert um scenario well i we we
reported earlier today that the dolphins
were
thinking about and planning to go after
brady and sean payton as a package deal
and i don't think brady's done i think
brady's done with the bucks and i think
brady is retired for the off-season
and he said it himself on his podcast
when he when he uttered the never say
never line which got most of the
attention the other thing that caught my
ear was him saying that when june and
july rolls around he doesn't know how
he's going to feel because that was
dangerously close to what brett favre
said to david letterman april 2008 when
he was retired and nobody thought he was
coming back and he said something along
the lines of when training camp rolls
around something's bound to happen i was
like holy crap this guy's coming back
and and when brady says i don't know how
i'm gonna feel well you know what i know
how he's gonna feel and you know how
he's gonna feel and everybody listening
knows how he's gonna feel he's going to
feel like i can't let this sport go
forward without me because i'm good
enough to still play so maybe he
placates gisele with four months at home
and she realizes you know what
four months is enough
and uh whether it's the dolphins whether
it's the 49ers i still think he's going
to end up the 49ers but i just think
he's done with the buccaneers he retired
from the buccaneers not from football
and maybe that's why that statement only
mentioned the buccaneers and it was
every single person in the organization
who was who was thanked maybe the real
message is he's retiring from the
buccaneers
and you're reporting that that that um
brady's retired and sean payton steps
away
um
and
and then the dolphin swooped in and said
how about the both of you together right
here before they hired mike mcdaniel
that's what you're saying they were
planning to go after both guys and the
flores lawsuit resulted in them pulling
the plug on it i don't know whether they
decided to pull the plug or maybe the
league office said you can't do this
because of the flores lawsuit but you
know i i poked around yesterday and
sought comment from the dolphins and on
the record they declined comment but off
the record multiple team sources said
that they actually made a request for
permission
to speak to sean payton after payton
resigned from the saints and the saints
declined
the request for permission which is odd
to me because you you can number one get
him out of the conference because
everybody thinks he's coming back to the
cowboys at some point number two you get
something for him and with brady
all that dolphin sources would
acknowledge is there's been internal
discussions about him becoming a
minority owner because he's very close
with bruce beal the number two guy in
ownership who's eventually presumably
going to take over the team from stephen
ross so
uh but but look
hey brady is the unnamed quarterback in
the flores lawsuit that flores claimed
steven ross tried to get him to tamper
with the patriots were petrified two
years ago that brady was going to land
with the dolphins because of the beale
connection so yeah that was that was a
thing until the brian flores lawsuit
came along and made it not a thing
mike as always a great chat uh i greatly
appreciate it and uh look for my call
post combine prior to your book coming
out uh my platform is yours compadre
thank you appreciate it
thank you that is mike florio at pro
football talk so many
items
are food for thought right there to say
the least
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here